es reicht mir ich war ja seit 20 jahren
elektroautos unter anderem das her und
es tut sich einfach nichts bis zu wenig
biss zu dilettantisch wenn jetzt auf
einen schlag 30.000 id3 von volkswagen
auf die straßen kommen dann wird sich
schnell zeigen was für ein crêpe die
lade plätze ladesäulen laden netze sind
kaputt chaos teuer
ihr merkt ich lasse mal wieder dampf ab
und felix bellinger vom kanal felix ba
unterstützt mich wie weshalb warum los
geht's herzlich willkommen und für alle
ungeduldigen über das oder den link in
der video beschreibung kommt ihr zur
petition von felix und mir um die es
jetzt gehen wird das kann doch wirklich
nicht wahr sein
da kommen jetzt hier in deutschland
100.000 elektroautos auf die straßen und
wir sind so gut vorbereitet wie auf eine
pandemie nämlich gar nicht bei corona
fehlte die schutzausrüstung unser
gesundheitsminister hat geschlampt und
hier hat an die scheuer unser
verkehrsminister geschlampt die
ladeinfrastruktur ist auf diesen ansturm
überhaupt nicht vorbereitet ich war ja
ein modell s von tesla cedric vom kanal
doktor watson fährt das model 3 und
hatte mir empfohlen doch mal nasa gut
planer auszuprobieren da werden dann
nicht nur super charger von tesla in der
routenplanung angeboten sondern auch
andere ladesäulen was soll ich sagen es
war ein desaster
allein forderten hauptzentrale in essen
musste ich eine stunde pause einlegen
die ladesäule tat es einfach nicht und
der support naja mein telefon gespräch
mit ihm geben sie mir mal bitte die
nummer der ladesäule ja danke die sonne
steht kann ich von der e.on
hauptzentrale die steht woanders die ich
doch ich sehe sie hier vor mir sie steht
hier in aller pracht aber tut es nicht
letztlich konnte mir der support nicht
helfen und oh wunder nach ein paar mal
rein und raus stecken tat sie es dann
doch was für ein wahnsinn ich habe 99
stunden von köln nach berlin gebraucht
da muss sich niemand wundern wenn
elektroautos durch den kakao gezogen
werden ich nutze jetzt nur noch super
charger von tesla auf der langstrecke
und felix der hat
erfahrungen gemacht ich sage mal so ich
fahre ja ein model 3 also einen tesla
und solange ich mich im super charger
netzwerk auf faltet geht's und solange
ich mich auch in leipzig aufhalte geht
es auch weil wir hier eine super
ladeinfrastruktur haben aber in anderen
städten ist es manchmal wirklich gerade
in berlin habe ich häufiger mal probleme
und wenn ich mal mit dem anderen auto
unterwegs bin laden sich texte auch
häufiger mal fahrzeuge wie audi audi e
tron oder niveau sowie da ist es sehr
schnell dann so dass das ladenetz auf
der langstrecke ein bisschen zum
bröckeln anstrengend mit kaputten
ladestationen mit besetzten
ladestationen und so weiter und es geht
weiter in köln gibt es so gut wie keine
öffentlichen ladesäulen in berlin sind
sie aus faulheit missverständlich
beschildert quiz frage wer dafür wie
lange parken knoten im kopf den haben
selbst erfahrene polizisten und
polizistinnen wenn sie davor stehen
verbrenner fahrer und fahrerin sowie
sowie auf tik tok dokumentiert bekomme
ich da ab und zu schlechte laune
[Musik]
es ist einfach alles ziemlich halbherzig
und um engagiert umgesetzt auf bundes
und auf kommunaler ebene
wir brauchen einfach ein gutes regelwerk
deshalb haben felix balinger vom kanal
felix barth und ich jetzt bei change.org
eine petition gestartet weil es so
einfach nicht funktioniert sie ist
provokant und überspitzt aber sie sagt
was notwendig ist und als ich felix
gefragt habe aber dabei ist hat er
sofort zugesagt ist aber so ich glaub
ich hab einfach vor allem die sorge dass
wenn jetzt die elektroauto flut so
richtig losgeht und mehr leute merken
haye ein elektroauto ist das richtige
für mich die ersten aldi drais werden
ausgeliefert und so weiter und so fort
wenn es ganz normal richtig ins rollen
kommt dass unsere infrastruktur einfach
nicht so gut darauf vorbereitet ist wie
sie es sein sollte mich möchte
mein teil dazu beitragen zu versuchen zu
verhindern dass es dass wir in den
nächsten jahren ein absolutes lade chaos
bei uns auch schon straßen haben
zahlreiche forderungen haben wir bis
ende 2020 aufgestellt das ist schon bald
aber das ist auch der zeitpunkt an dem
sie spätestens realisiert sein müssten
und das ist absolut klar dass manches
davon nicht mehr geht aber es ist dann
aber auch einfach zu spät die
elektromobilität wird einen ziemlich
schlechten ruf bei den vielen
beschwerden bekommen und schuld daran
ist mal wieder unser an die scheuer
deswegen braucht er und die gesamte
politik jetzt richtig druck und zwar
nicht durch ein bürokratisches
petitionsverfahren dass sich hier in
berlin was die beschilderung angeht auch
gerade durch das dauert aber äonen bist
du eine verwaltung der antwortet da
fließt viel wasser die spree runter also
bitte unterstützt diese petition
unterzeichnet sie und ganz wichtig
verbreitet sie es ist mehr als dringend
der link ist hier unter me wie gesagt in
der video beschreibung und hier
hoffentlich im bild also tausend dank an
alle die schon dabei sind haut rein bis
dann bleibt dran